There are many physical problems
in which a body undergoes
motion about a central point.
And when that happens, there's
a natural coordinate system
to describe that motion,
which in two dimensions
is polar coordinates.
So let's consider the
orbit of an object.
For instance, the best
example is a circular orbit.
If we have a circular
orbit of an object,
there is a central point,
which we'll call P.
Now given this type of
motion with an object,
it naturally makes sense to
choose a coordinate system
called polar coordinates.
The way that coordinate
system works is as follows.
First off, we need to
choose a reference angle.
And so we'll choose
a horizontal line.
And we'll draw a ray.
And we'll show a direction
of increasing reference angle
theta.
In this example, theta
will go from 0 to 2 pi.
Along with the reference
angle, we have a distance
from the central point.
And that distance
we'll refer to as r.
So the coordinates of our
point are r and theta.
Now the variable r is
always greater than r
and can go to infinity--
greater than 0.
So this is our polar
coordinate system.
When you have a
coordinate system,
remember, at every
point in space,
there has to be unit vectors.
So at this point right here,
how do we choose unit vectors
for polar coordinates?
We always choose
the unit vectors
to point in the increasing
direction of the coordinate.
Take the r-coordinate.
That increases radially outward.
So our unit vectors
here will have a r hat
pointing radially outward.
What about the theta direction?
Tangential to the circle,
in this particular case.
Because theta is increasing
in this direction,
we choose our
tangential unit vector,
which we're going to call theta
hat, which is at right angles
to r hat, to point in the
direction of increasing theta.
And so at this point, we now
have a set of unit vectors.
Now one has to be very
careful in polar coordinates
for the following reason.
Suppose that you're at
another point over here.
Now because we have
two different points,
let's just give some
names to these points.
We'll call this s1
and this point s2.
And the unit vector's over
here where r1 and theta were.
When we're at the
point as 2, we have
to choose unit vectors
exactly the same way.
r hat 2 points in the direction
of increasing r, and theta hat
2 points in the direction
of increasing theta.
So what we see in
polar coordinates
is that r hat 1 is
not equal to r hat 2.
Why are they not equal?
They both are unit
vectors, so they both have
the same magnitude, but they
point in opposite directions,
in the same way that theta hat
1 is not equal to theta hat 2.
So unlike Cartesian coordinates,
in which at every single point
had the same unit vectors,
in polar coordinates,
the unit vectors depend
on where you are in space.
And that will make our
analysis on polar coordinates
a little bit more complicated.